men who are
maybe struggling in the dating world
because i think
i think a lot of people don't realize
that most guys are struggling like 30 of
guys under 30 are virgins do what i mean
um
if there was one thing you could ask
them what would you ask them
well why would i ask them if they're
struggling i don't know or
well to help them oh like but i wouldn't
ask them a question to help them
you wouldn't want you don't help them
well
i'm just thinking when you ask when you
help someone you tell them to do
something when you ask a question
usually you want advice
i was gonna ask well if i was gonna ask
them a question to help them then i'd
probably ask them like
questions about like what they're doing
now so they could get better results in
the future so i probably like i probably
start with just like go get checked
because i feel like being jack gives you
like two points as a dude
you can take an average looking guy if
he's strong like you get you get like
two points it doesn't matter about
height
well you can't change your height yeah
it matters but like what are you gonna
do about it yeah yeah that's true yeah i
hear that i hear that i hear that
um
is there anything you want to bring up
two men and women
two men and women yeah i know you do a
lot of talking in your own show but
not really i rolled out of bed before
this interview she really did
very offended
and i had to go pick her up as well the
audacity
um don't use the audacity on me yeah i
use that boy
the audacity
um
oh i'll grill you
[Music]
um
oh no
i'm scared
we're
um
she set up and everything she's ready no
i'm thinking i'm thinking
how's a girl ever been
now i know the answer to this question
i'm literally thinking what have i told
him in the past before no
um
okay has a girl ever has a girl
overstalked you
yes tell me about that oh uh well this
was a girl who was like
she'd seen me in a couple of my shows
so she was a little bit of a fan
and i was like oh
that's fun that's cool someone who like
loses you is like a nice inspiration
likes what you do
so we went on a couple of dates she was
really nice she seemed all cool
but then
huh you can't date fans you can't well
this is what i learned you can't you
can't this is what i learned you can't
so it was like
and i'll ask you the same so it was like
well in a few days it was cool it was
nice i just didn't feel the vibe is
right
so then i just said to her that i
think she's great but i think we should
just be friends nothing more
um
and then she just showed up at my house
a couple of times to be honest she
showed up at your house yeah i lived at
my dad's at the time and she showed up
at my dad's um
like claiming like she left something in
my car
and i'm like
that was like two weeks ago like how
have you left it there
um what'd your dad say
i don't know if i should say what you
said what'd he say he's like what do you
do to these girls i was like i don't do
anything
we actually didn't do anything so
but yeah i think that's that's the worst
your dad is what do you do is this a
common occurrence does this happen more
than once
no it's not happening more
no no are you hesitating no because i
was i was thinking okay so like usually
i interview people so usually when
people hesitate it means they're like
thinking of a story
so like i was thinking if a couple of
stories qualify for you asking for okay
but they're close they're kind of close
that's how you thought about them that's
how i had to think about them so they
start you somewhere else
not stalking i i it's hard to start like
because people stalk people on social
media it's kind of more like so like
burner accounts
do you have some burner accounts that
watch your story immediately ladies you
already know
you know
um
abusers 5432
user 543xy
i know you're watching um no i know a
couple of
maybe
but yeah because social media like
everybody can have so much access to
what's going on in your life if you post
enough so they don't actually need to
physically stalk you do you want do you
know what i mean yeah um i don't know i
should ask saying to you have you ever
dated a fan before
an experience with oh that's a that's a
something that wasn't a no
no because i interviewed people too
i've gone on a date with the fan but
there was no second date sorry why what
happened
nothing really to be honest it wasn't
like it was just i don't know like it
was fine and then you just don't wanna
you know but
yeah have you ever been stalked
no
you've never been stalked no i don't
think so you're being stalked right now
you just don't know it someone's
probably talking about i get nervous
sometimes
i get scared sometimes
like it's just i have had someone
threatened to come beat me up in my
apartment i'm more scared of women to be
honest than men
oh really why is that because they're
crazy
because a man knows if he hits me like
there's consequences or like a woman
like they just get away with everything
so
like yeah this girl was like threatening
to come to my apartment and beat me up
[Music]
your friend jess who if anybody watches
post channel you would see
she used to have uh
what you would call kind of the modern
woman's mindset in regards to dating in
men right and then you kind of red
pilled her so she wasn't too bad oh she
was already kind of on the wavelength or
um i mean i think everyone's every
girl's kind of modern to some extent
mm-hmm like you don't really have like
of course yeah yeah um but i mean she's
really open-minded
but she like there's some girls that are
like super
too far gone but she was kind of in the
middle she didn't but then
you just show her stuff and she's like
oh i see what you're saying yeah yeah
but yeah go ahead no well i was just
gonna say what was um
how how was her cause she's a female
friend of yours and i know you said you
know you've kind of felt that some
female friends people might have
distanced themselves because of your
views yeah et cetera et cetera because
they've said that so like word for word
they have said that yeah but there you
go yeah
i think that but she
obviously she's still a close friend and
maybe her opinions have shifted i want
to see how much have they shifted in
regards to
you know the things that you say about
women and men and things no no i would
say she
no she looks at the world different too
because it's like once you see it you
can't see it the world discriminates
against men
even even in our language like he
knocked her up
why is it on him
yeah that's true
she got pregnant like you take it's even
even in our language like we take
accountability off of women well i
i hear that
but what i would say is um
is there not an element if you want a
man to be the leader then he does have
to take responsibility
for the people that he wants to lead
right would you say most women are
letting men lead
most women in relationships or
i think so yeah because i think happy
relationships are quiet you don't hear
about them you only hear about the bad
ones and i think there's more happy ones
that people realize